شكرا جزيلا السيد الرئيس
قبل عام
تحدثنا هاتفيا
كان الوقت متاخرا في الولايات المتحده
ومبكرا في الولايات المتحده دخلت الدبابات
الروسيه الى اوكرانيا قلت لي انك كنت تسمع
التفجيرات في
على مقربه من مكانك واتذكر جيدا عندما
سالتك
ماذا يمكن ان افعله السيد الرئيس كيف يمكن
ان اساعدك
وادرك ما قلته لي وهناك تبس
يجمع قاده العالم
واطلب منهم دعم اوكرانيا
اجمع قاده العالم واطلب منهم دعم اوكرانيا
قلت انك تتعلم
لا تدري متى يمكن ان نتواصل
مجددا
قبل عام
كان العالم ينتظر سقوط اكياس
يبدو وكان الوقت اطول من عام
ربما
نهايه اوكرانيا ايضا
تعلم بعد عام لا تزال كيف واقفه وكذلك
اوكرانيا لا تزال واقفه مقراتيه قائمه
المتحده تقف معك والعالم يقف معك
وكيف قد استولت على جزء من قلب جئت الى
هنا ست مرات كان نائب للرئيس ومره كرئيس
في عام 2009 كان نائب للرئيس عندما جئت
الى هنا لمره الاولى وفي عام 2014 عدت
ثلاث مرات في عقاب بثوره الكرامه ثم عدت
في عام 2015
للوقوف على العمل من اجل بناء الديمقراطيه
قويه
وجئت في عام 2017 قبل ان اغادر منصبي
كنائب للرئيس كنت اعرف انني ساعود لكنني
لم اعرف متى حتى بعد الانتخابات
قررت انه يجب ان اقوم بزياره اخرى قبل
يتم تنصيب رئيس المقبل الى كيف اذا الرئيس
لقد شرفتني هنا في كيف الى جانبك اليوم
لتقي مع الجنود
والمس الاستخبارات ودبلوماسيين وقاده
المجتمع الذين ساعدوا بلدهم وقفوا الى
جانبه وقت الحاجه الجميع وقفوا الى جانب
بلادهم الجميع
النساء
والشباب
حاولوا ان يقوموا بشيء ما
يحاولون ان يخرجوا الناس من المباني التي
تعرضت للقصف
في جرائم ضد الانسان امر مذهل العالم
باسره راى ذلك
ونظر الى ذلك
انها اوسع حرب في اوروبا منذ ثلاثه ارباع
القرن ولقمتم تحققون النجاح ضد كل
التوقعات باستثناء توقعاتكم نحن وثقون
بانكم سوف تواصلون تحقيق الانتصار
عندما
تلقيت الاتصال هاتفي بشان الخوف من سقوط
كيف قبل عام كنا نركز على تحديد كيف يمكن
حشد دعم العالم كيف يمكن ان اساعدك في
الوعد الذي طلبته مني وهو جمع قاده العالم
كيف تحقق النجاح كيف يمكن ان نحث العالم
على الاستجابه
من اجل اقتصاد مزدهر وبلد ديمقراطي ودوله
امنه ومستقره عندما
اتحد الامريكيون
قرروا الوقوف
الشعب الامريكي يدرك
بان الغزوه والعدوان هو تهديد لنا جميعا
بنين تحالف للدول من الاطلس الى الهادي
النيتو
واليابان في المحيط الهادي اي في العالم
برمته
عدد من الدول عددها تجاوز الخمسين
صاعده هذه الدول الاوكرانيه للدفاع النفسي
وقدمت الدعوه الانساني والاقتصادي نحن
قاده العالم نريد
[موسيقى]
التكلفه على روسيا تؤثر على شريان حياتها
الاقتصادي معا قدمنا حوالي 700 دبابه
والالاف من العربات المدرعه والف من
الانظمه انظمه المدفعي واكثر من مولاي
ذخيره واكثر من خمسين انظمه
الصواريخ المتقدمه ونظام انظمه الدفاع
كلها قدمت للدفاع عن اوكرانيا وطبعا
بالاضافه الى 500 مليون دولار سنععلن عنه
اليوم
وهذا يتعلق بالولايات المتحده فقط واليوم
فقط هذا الاعلان يشمل ايضا ذخائر لمدفع
هاي مارس والمزيد من جافلينز وكذلك
رادارات الرقابه لحمايه الشعب الاوكراني
من القصف الجوي وفي وقت لاحق هذا الاسبوع
سنعلن عقوبات اضافيه ضد
النخبى التي تريد ان تتلافى العقوبات
وتساعد روسيا بفضل دعم للحزبين في الكونغو
سنقدم هذا الاسبوع المليارات من الدعم
المالي المباشر من الميسانيه حيث يمكن
للحكومه الاوكراني تستخدم ذلك فورا لتقديم
الخدمات الاساسيه للمواطنين
التكلفه التي على اوكرانيا تحملها باهظه
الى حد كبير
وضحايا اعظم
مما يتوقع نحن
في حاله حداد على أويك الذين قتلوا في هذه
الحرب الوحشيه غير الظالمه ندرك ان سيكون
هناك ايام وشهور واشهر وسنوات صعبه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
روسيا كانت ترغب في محو اوكرانيا من على
الخريطه لكن خطه بوتين فشلت وروسيا فقدت
نصف الاراضي التي احتلتها
وشباب الروس يفرون بعشرات الالاف لا
يريدون ان يعودوا الى روسيا
ليس فقط من بين الجيش ولكن يهربون من
روسيا نفسها لانهم لا يرون اي مستقبل في
بلادهم
الاقتصاد الروسي الان في حاله تخلف ومعزول
ويعاني
اعتقد بوتين ان اوكرانيا ضعيفه وان الغرب
منقسم
وكما تعلمون السيد رئيس قلت لك في البدايه
يمكن ان تعول علينا وسنتقف جنبا الى جنب
انه كان يعول على ابقاء النيت متحده يعاون
علينا ان لن نستطيع ان نجلب اخرين الى
نيته الى جانبي اوكرانيا
اعتقد انه يمكن ان يبقى ولكن لا اعتقد انه
يفكر بهذا الامر الان
لا سادري ما يمكن ان يفكر به بل انه
مختل ربما
وقد يثبت انه مخطئ بعد عام مضى
الدليل موجود هنا في هذه القاعه نجد هنا
جنبا الى جنب السيد الرئيس
انا سعيد انني استطعت ان اعيد لك الزياره
الى في بلدك بعدما قدمت الى واشنطن قلت
انه ليس لدينا ايه مخاوف ولا ينبغي لاي
كان في العالم ان يكون لديه مخاوف انتهى
الاقتباس السيد رئيس والشعب الاوكراني
تذكرون العالم كل يوم
معنا الشجاعه
كفت القطاعات هنا
كل فئات المجتمع متحدون وهذا امر مذهل
وهذا يذكرنا بان الحريه لا ثمن لها
[موسيقى]
ان هذه الحريه تستحق ان يضحي الانسان من
اجلها مهما طال الزمن سيد رئيس وهذا ما
سنقدمه لكم من دعم طال زمن ام قصر